redewendungen
teil 2
die ohren spitzen
aufmerksam zuhören
willkommen liebe klasse zu unserer
heutigen stunde
heute befassen wir uns mit dem thema
redewendungen
willkommen liebe klasse zu unserer
heutigen stunde
heute befassen wir uns mit dem thema
redewendungen
redewendungen können im alltag benutzt
werden und sind wichtig um ein schöneres
deutsch zu sprechen
redewendungen können im alltag benutzt
werden und sind wichtig um ein schöneres
deutsch zu sprechen
also hört aufmerksam zu und spitz teure
uhren
das gefällt mir schon viel besser
das gefällt mir
viel besser
legen wir los
jemanden ins herz schließen
jemanden in
herz schließen
etwas liebgewinnen zuneigung zu jemanden
entwickeln
danke liebling dass du ihm diesen hund
gekauft hast danke liebling dass du ihm
diesen hund gekauft hast
er hat ihn sofort ins herz geschlossen
das habe ich gerne gemacht
ich habe ihn auch sehr lieb gewonnen
morgen gehen wir mit ihm in die
hundeschule
wirklich schade
dass er schon wieder gehen muss
ich hatte ihn schon in mein herz
geschlossen
schon in mein herz geschlossen
[Musik]
jemanden auf die palme bringen
jemanden wütend machen
provozieren ärgern
guten morgen liebe klasse
[Musik]
guten morgen liebe klasse ich bitte um
eure aufmerksamkeit
ich bitte um eure aufmerksamkeit
bitte ruhe bitte versuchen sie mich
nicht zu provozieren
versuchen sie mich nicht zu provozieren
macht doch was ihr wollt
jetzt haben sie mich schon wieder auf
die palme gebracht
jetzt haben
nun wieder auf die palme gebracht
das heft in der hand halten
derjenige sein der die entscheidungen
trifft die macht haben
dieses rennen werde ich gewinnen
heute habe ich das sagen
ich wusste immer dass ich gewinnen werde
wir hatten keine
chance
wir hatten keine chance
sie hat das heft nie aus der hand
gegeben
auf großem fuß leben
gut luxuriös
aufwändig leben
ihr geld ausgeben
gut luxuriös
aufwändig leben viel geld ausgeben
ich wünschte ich hätte mehr
ein größeres haus und ein neues auto
ich wünschte ich hätte mehr geld für ein
größeres haus und ein neues auto
dein wunsch soll in erfüllung gehen
das neue haus und das auto sind der
wahnsinn
es hat schon
eine vorteile auf großem fuß zu leben
schon seine vorteile auf großem fuß zu
leben
alles unter einen hut bringen
unterschiedliche dinge miteinander
vereinbaren zusammenfassen
derzeit seine frau
muss er alles alleine machen
seit seine frau verstorben ist muss er
alles alleine machen
ja es ist sehr bewundernswert wie er die
arbeit und die familie unter einen hut
bringt
ja es ist sehr bewundernswert wie er die
arbeit und die familie unter einen hut
bringt
jemand dem hals und beinbruch wünschen
jemandem viel glück und gutes gelingen
wird
wünschen
guten morgen
klasse
[Musik]
guten morgen
klasse
ich hoffe ihr habt alle gut aufgepasst
und die neuen redewendungen gelernt
ich hoffe
ihr habt alle gut aufgepasst und die
neuen redewendungen gelernt
wie
vizrt findet heute die prüfung statt
den test wünsche ich euch hals und
beinbruch
für den test wünsche ich euch hals und
möchtest du gratis online deutsch lernen
mehr als 200 video lektionen abonniere
unseren kanal möchtest du gratis online
deutsch lernen mehr als 200 video
lektionen abonniere unseren kanal